Yeah right welcome to a new game now try
this miss Morrow again it worked nicely
last game yeah well don't know the lines
is playing a skinning and type of setup
Queen 85 looks a bit strange don't know
what this movie is exactly trying to
achieve I play Bishop f4 x + 5 y am the
queen is certainly not well placed them
can also play night b5 just winning the
pawn probably ok let's go for this
don't see how you would put protect it
can hardly return with the Queen you
five maybe okay so should I just take it
yeah come on shouldn't be too bad
e 6 amazing really seems to believe he's
got all the time in the world here he's
gotten really am still no development
foresee a time time just kicking this
night now I was more expecting expecting
something like e five let's take n t5
something like this to get to get the
bishop out
I'm not quite sure what he's doing now
this night on d6 it's the problem I'm
down I may simply play a h3 and what is
the night doing really wow if I take me
six this isn't e6 just down just a
problem okay let's take this rook f6
what should I play on rook f6 I could I
could simply take c 8 this should should
really win rockville should be six
coming not sure what what he does to
prevent this just Fischer b6 coming and
now queen e6 even made right Quinn g8
mate
checkmate yeah this was quick yeah
people sometimes play really weird stuff
against the moral gambit and then you
get get some nice games like here yes
thanks for watching